this is this is great you know here in
California we have medicinal marijuana
and weed is now illegal for recreation
use in Colorado and in Washington and
the California Democratic Party has
passed a resolution this past weekend
asking for or now backing legalizing
weed in this state altogether
recreational medicinal the whole thing
the problem here is that the feds are
completely against this and our
President Barack Obama who has sort of
always been this kind of cool you know
there's stories of him smoking some weed
and he jokes about it at the Washington
Correspondents Dinner he's still raiding
legal weed dispensaries here in
California now so I want to start with
talking about Obama here is is this just
really bizarre about him personally
where he's made it clear he has smoked
weed and does not have a problem with
smoking weed and yet for some reason
still is ordering the feds to raid
medicinal marijuana dispensaries here in
California I've never understood it I've
just never understand I've never
understood it under any president and
especially now when it when states are
one-by-one making it legal I don't know
if you spend one dollar and twenty
minutes on this that is an enormous
waste of resources so does it make it
seem like this doesn't have to do with
him and it has to do with the bigger
sort of government and the way that
there what's federal right yeah exactly
that he that somehow even though
personally he made I don't want to give
him a pass on this one though this seems
like something that's so obviously he's
personally for and yet doesn't do what
do you think it's possible that he's so
worried about his legacy now that he
doesn't want to be known as like you
know the president who was so left cuz
everyone grieves in that they call Mike
a socialist Nazi which doesn't make
sense it's like you're using to like
antonyms or something I don't know
either way I think that sometimes there
could be a little bit of fear with him
that he doesn't want to be known as the
president that was like sure have we not
you know be so hot that we love in gala
because he's come out you know finally
he's come out in support of you know
game
he's come out in support of a lot of
other things that people associate with
being liberal and he's raised the dead a
lot and I just don't know if he wants to
be that guy who everyone goes was the
most liberal president in history
because he wants to see maybe a little
bit more moderate I think that's
possible except the part that doesn't
quite jive with me on that is he could
just say nothing about this and just not
order the feds this comes from the feds
so it's his administration he could just
do nothing and let California do
whatever they're doing super to the
right and go these are states rights
which would appease the right to impede
conservatives and if they say anything
about it he'd have to go well look at
what you say you say you want to be able
to control abortion in your own state
you want to be want to control all these
things in your own state your state's
rights people if your conservative
states rights and just drop the
microphone and run Eve it alone right
but it's like with abortion and with gay
rights they only believe in states
rights when the the government is not
doing what they want them to do so dude
what do you think in terms of just the
battle between the state and the fed
here should a state have more power to
control what their state's laws yeah
absolutely but only the things that I
agree a little bit upset when you hear
that a certain state at least you for me
personally I go there banning abortion
or there's something that I'm like
however they do that the federal
government needs to step in and say they
can't do that because we did it it I
have the right I'm like well we don't
have a constitutional right to abortion
so maybe that is a states rights thing
and I will get heated about that so I
understand but that being said I don't
know if marijuana itself is is making
people in other states so angry that
they're going on California make sure
they don't get their weed I don't know
if that's as much as an emotional that's
the part that seems bizarre to me
because I can understand the abortion
issue is a life or death issue
regardless of what side you're on
but the weed thing this is basically
something that people do in the privacy
of their own home that does not cause
any violence or car accidents there's no
study you know a little you get giddy
food all the hack jokes we can do about
that
protesting many marijuana things the way
they protest like abortion clinics and
things like that it's not as heated it
sounds personal even though it's a
highly personal choice it's not as
personal of an issue doesn't inflame
people so I don't understand maybe the
DEA needs to keep going for some reason
or they need a hobby I don't to me
doesn't make sense either why this
federal could this be a money thing
could this purely be a
anything that somehow by keeping weed
illegal the government in a weird way is
making money you know if we really would
get it to some conspiracy level because
of smoking weed maybe it has something
to do with that when you keep the war on
drugs going because they're getting
back-end money somehow in the Fed and
something like that
financial incentive to keep this going
on there has to be some sort of deal
with whoever's running the drugs versus
government that there's something going
on who knows what it is but it's gone
past what people care about and the
whole public pretty much is like we
don't care who the Mokes we leave people
alone there's got to be financial things
going on yeah you can buy the for always
grow your own right just keep it a
backyard operation right keep it in your
own which actually in California now if
you are licensed to do it you can grow
your own and and just hope I guess that
the feds won't bust in on that for some
given oh because they can always figure
out some reason to do something right